there are part of the discussion a large
part was a discussion for the the
question of the democrats democratic
deficit to help about obviously about
austerity appointees in particular the
time that we ended up thinking the
ability to enlarge the debate way to
charge for the censored version of the
different relationship to a larger the
sinner on the European public sphere and
to treat nominally the perception and be
the reality of the fragmented and
dysfunctional urban atmosphere and it's
true and it's indication for the reviews
so we started the human with theoretical
discussion with emotions cruiser and
on the conditions of enlarging the
concept of the peninsula to Europe since
his concept as you all know was forced
to describe the process of evolution
with the National species and their
subsequent centers throughout the year a
ready voting representation of the more
unhealthy grounded work and it should be
sinners centered on a specific aspect of
the European public sphere by looking
some of the conditions of production and
dissemination of IT s in Europe today so
we have a singer on the question of
language here among the church formation
of media on the transformation of the
void intellectuals on the role of
interns and political foundation in your
to sob we went very interested in
thinking about the empirical conditions
of the premise here tonight our last
meeting Alice enough we go back remarks
to a more general discussion and
30 p granted discussion on the european
the European public sphere with Craig
Helen and every nothing of a better
person to wrap up the senator because
trans work has in illuminating
throughout the year by keen interest in
the contribution of the social sciences
to the public sphere to be understanding
LNG the making of the public sphere
proclaiming is a sociologist he holds
actually an amen in sociology and
anthropology from kroger system he was a
talented at but service internet
somewhere any of the kitchen from Oxford
as you all know he has contributed to
widely and TP to the field of social
theory but always is a central provision
I think that Amber's in the seminar
always fed with a home visit with the
devil with comparing all senses with
sociology with history many books both
EDT books and
I will put our plan we couldn't do that
with our attention on nationalism
initiative as several times and the book
and shine opportunity specimen book on
the other gentleman protests of each of
1989 which is called neither girls North
effort Craig I've had a very real and
carrier which some people might miss
colombia for for some time but is the
forum time at unc and then it was my
duty and so it was he was resigning from
96 on recently so it well and anyone who
founded institute for public knowledge
and it was also of course the director
of the social science research council
found 1999-2000 as well and since 2012
he crossed the atlantic and go the
president the director of the both of
the london school of economics and so
that's what it was a science so all
these mini recently extremely lucky and
happy to have
I think I'm overdressed I'm not going to
continue to a strip tease for us John
entire show up so I do have a walk
engaged with Columbia I'm tuning box i
am in anthropology an apt in sociology
left without finishing my doctorate and
come did eventually finishing a doctor
oxford the autumn i joined columbia
faculty and also left that in a
premature away after of your a half so
so i have a history of loving it and
leading it i still love it if you don't
like my talk I will be leading garden us
oh and I will speak with some generality
as perhaps beep it's a wrap up I'm not
so sure about the theoretical depth
you'll have to judge and let me begin
with the day and also theoretical
practical moment to talk and explain
what I mean by dream of the
democratic-republican a slightly
roundabout way starting with i'll come
back to universities the LSE the level
of economics including the sciences
under occupation at the moment of about
a month ago server month ago a small
group protesting students and others
took over a suite of two rules on campus
and declared the creation of the Free
University of London this was not in
imitation of the free university of
amsterdam bird Free University of Berlin
or another set of three universities
with a different image of the term it
was something that connects two
different ideas free ideas about free
intellectual inquiry and how I be
distorted ideas come here ideas about
free from costs that are a little more
complicated the students issue demands
the first of which was for both free and
universally acceptable education they
elaborated this by saying first that it
should not be a prob she's not for
profit not a complex negotiation there
oh but then this is what we need there
should be no fees and no charges more
difficult for us to implement oh and
that it should be free to everyone not
only British citizens they'll see it's
actually a state university there about
that target fundamenta state and
certainly not funded by the state to
provide free education during the world
so on hearing aid announced listen as it
began with the we will occupy the LLC
into electrolytes creative her slaves
education my first thought was
absolutely we all believe in that and my
second thought was this is wildin I even
a realistic and this talk is about
bleeding and wildly not even unrealistic
things for perhaps I should say about
the tension between utopian ideals and
practical transformation of institutions
and reality but it's about this in a
specific context what not all that far
from questions about foster access or
freedom and purpose in higher education
but not precisely about the occupation
of the LLC let me very slightly that it
really should the growth of modern
universities has been deeply shaped on
the dream of a democratic public sphere
this dream of the Democratic public I
will suggest some old one and I'm not
going to try to go through the whole of
this history Oh from Renaissance and
Reformation and lighten Minh but it's
one of them has shaped the growth of the
university is an institution
universities are among other things and
it with differences in context next to
educate citizens for public
participation they are meant to do this
courtly by exemplifying rational
critical public debate that's why when
academics gathered big discussing big
issues of the day with great insight and
never simpin departmental politics in
science publication and openness about
data are seen as basic two processes of
the improvement of knowledge partly
through the
correction of error and so I want to
elaborate but one direction of
discussion would be what is happening to
the infrastructure of publicness in
intellectual life itself never be themes
ranging from the debates over the
availability of unbiased reviewers in
pharmaceutical journals through to the
issues of proprietorial ownership of
research it's access to public
scholarship and arrangement others that
are working the universities aren't only
publix they have other a chance like
preparing students for employment and
careers making advances in knowledge
your valued for technologies and
economic benefits cures to diseases and
of as well as system and indeed personal
satisfaction not a trivial innovation
for economics there are basic challenge
this year that take us back to the
issues raised though only raised path
explicitly by the Elysee occupiers that
is at first when I began to speak to a
series of meetings I think by free it
shouldn't really cost anything they
didn't mean somebody else hey but of
course a perfect reflection on a
skidding somebody else should pay and it
broke a conversation for them
conversation but should that be the
state but it really like the state
either and I had aroused and um and
therefore they were have mixed opinions
about states that was better
students but somewhat less than actually
being free and their faucets evolved
minus I once with well on their response
let's say safe didn't ask questions
exclusively like pays for what it is
they think should be free or questions
like who gets in about access the clock
remember universal access so is it
taxpayers parents and students
philanthropists who pay and what are the
implications if the payment is less than
adequate to offer high quality everyone
how is access racial for universal what
rights to those who get emitted and a
half how much harder you should exist
how should be organized now I'm going to
step back from these little issues for
higher education or more comment and
look at similar questions but with
similar questions in mind at the string
of the Democratic public because I think
the same sort of questions for rise in
general the university is not only one
of the creatures of the rise of the
public sphere shaped by it but it also
exemplifies some of the issues that are
challenges for the notion of a
democratic public today including issues
like who's in the people's and who's not
and how is this related to resources and
what structure of inequality house
compatible it's not irrelevant to the
occupation of the LLC for example that
the majority of the students are not
elysee students who are occupying the
space at the LLC and that the
was initiated by Dutch students arriving
in the wake of the recent protests in
the Netherlands few months ago over the
issue of cost and control in higher
education and secret to make an
international movement they didn't
necessarily identity folk I won't say
whether they knew or not they didn't
evoke and this year it could have been
in 1848 storage put event story of a
variety of periods in which integrating
intellectuals but sometimes with radical
ideas moved around were reshaping the
national international European history
and all of this the issues are different
in the UK where higher education is
organized and funded somewhat
differently from the Netherlands and
other countries that are still as
national differences but they don't
completely dominate a story and this
talk is organized in four parts first
most formal part of it I will offer what
really still only amounts to a sketch
Chester and gesturing to some history to
tyranny especially the end of this I
will pay particular attention to the
idea of a unified public sphere and
popular agency so the district or shadow
a theme that runs through some of the
theoretical and other debates over the
public sphere of what gets now often
called the public sphere is can you say
the can you use a definite models right
you have to say publix and recognize
they kind of do
these public Stanton Frazier we heard
from is one of those who has encouraged
the notion that there shouldn't be a
plane to a hegemonic public sphere that
there are multiple subaltern publix and
other ponies and this raises a question
but it raises a question that has both
political and practical book release and
a sort of philosophical issue travels
under the name of what is meant to
topical agency and I'm not going to ask
an enormous detail earlier suggested has
included things like can you say there
was a subjectivity to a democratic
public that it apps in some sense as a
subject and what does it mean when you
try to say something like that after
this I will take up tensions between
ideals and practicality with special
reference to institutions and moments
transformative moments and the
relationship between public's and
counter publics prominent in the
literature then I will look not only
very telegraphic Lee just devote two of
many challenges to the vibrancy of
public spheres in terms of critical
reason and finally I should speak
briefly to global this is significant
because of my talk like others make a
private info and there is a tendency in
the literature on the public sphere both
of those serious academic
and broader horrible experience for a
narrative of decline to dominate
sometime in the past the public spirit
was great probably it was in the 18th
century enlightened and that they have
traumatic democracy in France which
possibly is not your actual all of
prophecy do something about it Oh which
thrived among other things in salons
with it a tradition of oil and other
into numbers which worked in a
complicated way the devote aspects of
what we believe is paradigmatic public
sphere possibly it thrived in revolution
itself or possibly model is the
scholarship life you're here possibly
there a variety of other models what I
want to suggest to this is the common
narrative in decline narrative well the
US Senate it's pretty pitiful today it
is I don't challenge that they would but
right the narrative that says it was
lost a great debating chamber if only we
have a canvas is a narrative about an
era when elections were bought for
barrels of alcohol and of when the
relatively populist movements of that
day on were nurtured by key political
figures and the Senate was both based on
a minute waist narrower franchise and um
in of its organization as closely linked
of different ways to money inequality as
it is today so the narrative of decline
himself in golden nature's raised
questions about the old adage Columbia
faculty members Michael shows that was
made especially of raising some of these
questions but it's not just the golden
age it is the fact that I think we
confuse the issues of ideals and
institutions that in this particular
discourse included in its academic
literature the commitments to a set of
very strong ideals are made to appear
practical are significant only by being
embedded in claims that this existed
wants sometime somewhere and therefore
it can
I think there's a problem in that which
is well it can give this optimism for a
moment it tends to lead us to an account
of all the reasons we don't have a
democratic public sphere and there are
plenty of those but I think they aren't
sufficient to suggest the ideal is
irrelevant now the history and theory
treated savages background oh I of your
whiteness program in primary subjects
report variations the promise of
democracy with the least in part is the
citizens can they collective choices not
only about short term policies but about
the kind of institutions and future that
they we want to have much political
debate is about the very immediate and
sometimes we tend to confuse democracy
with how we make these very immediate
decisions there are relatively few
constitutional found among us the kind
of Honor event celebrated talking up US
history or even the beginnings and early
phases of the European community under
in Union but there are times recurrent
times when you shape institutions this
is basic to democracy
because it means really changing the
conditions of our collective life
together as opposed to simply meetings
or practical challenges the possibility
of doing this chance not just on
elections and other constitutional
features of democratic government but
also on commitments to some idea of the
public good even the very idea that
there is a public good and participation
in public communication to establish
what it is guidance pursuit this is a
claim against the authority for
necessity of monarchs and dictators but
also for the possibility of choosing a
way of life and an organization of
social solidarity by contrast to simply
inheriting them or putting up with what
is engineered from above for diversions
from other sources not surprisingly
there have been many skeptics 1925
walter Lippmann famously suggested that
the public was a phantom at most a
reference point for establishing the
collective interest the not a meaningful
part of the process for ascertaining but
policies would actually serve that
interest solving problems he said
required experts an effective
administration but not mark scale public
action or debate the defense argument is
probably most remembered today for
occasional John duties counter-argument
but it actually was itself why wait
doing in response over the spirits of
defensive democracy and the centrality
of public engagement to democracy there
are many aspects of this is where do we
outlined some of his ideas about
democracy as necessarily an educated
process is a process not simply a
decision to mom already fully formed
people let alone a fully formed public
but of the self education of the people
in public he part of doing ideas in a
sense littleman can be seen as the foil
to the entire ensuing development of the
academic study popular discussion of
democratic publix he said they don't
matter much that the real work policy
making and problem solving inevitably
gets done by political insiders most
people are mere bystanders not agents
most lack of technical mastery problems
sufficient to solve them and therefore
the democracy itself is best limited to
elections that check abuses of power or
resolve crisis another if this party
ladies as well as plenty people were
confused we're not short skeptics today
summary the technical nature policy
challenges is simply beyond translation
into the less precise terms of public
discussion european version of this is
that there needs to be on an enemy beat
policy sphere organized around the
institutions of europe distinct from
direct translation into politics in
issues in problems like the referendum
the production of a basic law that
experts could love and the public
wouldn't understand and its rejection
the variety of forms some worry that the
public simply doesn't care
secularization worries some of the power
religion and public spirit or ease
others trust in politicians and the
media is low political parties are weak
and relatively ineffective in focusing
recent debate on dishes no changes to
the truth would you like to across the
border in some countries such amis
debate is literally banned in others of
speeds are killed those bold enough to
raise questions about government
policies the print media have long
sustained
a web discussion that that won't stain
would equal public discussion are in
decline not just in terms of their
content but is the business model that
sustains them they broadcast or may not
be far behind in this regard make your
questions in the Asian Europe or how
should state subsidized weatherization
so stars for the impacts of different
things but here too with mainstream
media facing significant long-term
change my knowledge new electronic media
offer exciting possibilities like
interaction on a larger scale and over
longer distances but it is unclear
whether these possibilities will
outweigh the dominance of commercial and
entertaining uses there is a very large
world of activists oriented of
discussion of the internet and its
potential for democracy which for the
most part ignores the extent to which
the primary uses of the internet are
gambling and pornography and the amount
of the internet which is controlled by
proprietary all access restrictions and
therefore the difficulties in extending
the mere fact of the Internet to the
Democratic intopia that at least
technologically it might potentially
under other circumstances facilitating
the same new media have also killed
public life by their use to enable
intensive space surveillance massive
quartered compilations of personal data
of consumers and new
this is about my term involuntary
publicity as data sets are act and
documents leaked the term public in fact
invokes involuntary exposure as much as
collective debate not least of all there
is doubt as to whether transnational
public's can develop adequately to meet
the scale of transnational markets
social organizations problems and even
governance I don't know but a sea
creature spoke about when she was here
the part of the argument first this is
in fact that the public sphere simply
can't keep up with the global
organization how reasons to doubt the
project of the Democratic public sphere
seem as prominent today as they did in
fitness 19 25 and to top it off for many
of the idea of Liberty as a feature of
collective public life advanced by
government has fainted almost to
invisibility that is people contended to
lose touch with the idea that what they
might want and expect and actually gain
from government is an increase in
Liberty there's a great deal of
attention to how much government
restricts Liberty whether that's
necessarily true as many libertarians
would suggest or whether there are ways
with that which that cannot be true but
there is a loss in here you have this
part of this of faith in the idea that
government that
increase Liberty that is the
democratization transformation of
government but sometimes all the welfare
state other sorts of things could be an
agent of literacy this has been replaced
by an imaginary of markets an unfettered
private property as realms of a purely
individual liberty now again going into
this story in detail until here to say
that over over over again as I go
through this here this is not Cynthia
story of something that happened this of
every Road agents a shift in the way
people think about public and private
has been pursued for some decades by a
variety of a relatively well backed
interests this country and
internationally mont pelerin society for
example which celebrates links to
trigger hi Apollo it's considerably to
the right hiya itself up and I think
unfair to encourage I have to say that
because Hayek was an LZ professor of the
park society has been part of a
long-term campaign largely but not only
three courses partly through the media
and not insignificant
through financial backing of academics a
campaign focused on making the private
see national and the public artificial
idea that the private is a natural
expression of individual liberty the
public is necessarily an artificial and
therefore constraining once Russian this
appears there variety of forms but it's
worth thinking about calling how much is
the root for the idea of privacy is not
historically organ illogically about
personal liberty what about deprivation
the common loot with deprivation is lost
the reasons why a private soldier is the
lowest rank in the army listen to the
new discourse you would think that
private must be the highest the general
is the highest right the contrast is
indicative of something I a private
soldier is one who in fact doesn't have
others doesn't command any of em last
certain connections as you move up
through the ranks who to people who
actually have large numbers of other
people potentially never quite you can't
take that military
everywhere but it's intuitive impossible
yet in the very well you think about
some of the court runs the argument and
what has been pursued thank you for
example about land use policy or of the
rights of the press or various other
media and suit through the courts to
change very notions of us Ashley that is
a issuing in a variety of Supreme Court
rulings and others are significant to
the public sphere in the United States
issues in other complicated and
sometimes restrictive policies in Europe
but also shapes a European us converse
recently in the US this campaign has
been associated with neoliberals and
it's become one of these shif'less to
equate of American influence with a kind
of dominance and you know the rules and
I think that's not entirely helpful
partly because it allows one to think in
terms of those
miss some of the institutional
frameworks for example the European us
differences in copyright law I aren't
due to neoliberalism they predated
destruction for the copyright wars is
confusing us comparison system they
predated her grounded in other features
of the differences of legal frameworks
and broad cultural orientations to how
it is one might secure provides the
office specifically trivializing large
book of things like whether the rights
of authors in here in the person and
expire any one person's lifetime or our
property that can be transferred to
others and thus pass on years after
their key parts of dice is apart we can
be software me yes so the notions public
always currently dependent on the
contrast private are available for me
imagining in somewhere the reimagining
has been a least in part by a concerted
campaign a back to the nineteen twenties
shopjimmy answered little and directly
and almost immediately with an argument
that publix word in fact needed in order
to address the problems that arose from
the indirect consequences of social
action in complex large-scale societies
he writes all of admission
from academics but I'm not pretend I
thought vetted this idea in the 1980s of
what I read do me and the Republicans
problem discovered it even embedded this
idea some 60 years before I participated
years of employment history in realizing
how often there have been pretty
strawberries are often we've been traced
ideas back and stand on the shoulders of
giants but a basic feature of modern
societies is that there are actions that
create significant sometimes negative
consequences at in distance from those
who choose the actions they integrity
over those sense choose the actions in
them and in direct relationships so that
the much the organization of modern
society is not an extension of our
direct relationships whether they are of
satisfying primary relationships are
unsatisfied secondary relationships but
is in fact we're in direct relationships
shape in various ways including Marcus
public's this hasn't gone away we could
rethink capital is going to be a
different time in part as an entire
economic system for the production of
externalities and the ways in which
externalities any of them
all of our credits are organized becomes
a basic issue for capitalists and a
basic issue about who pays how we
organize this touch on this moment them
doing your answering livin thought the
actual performance of publix would be
improved enough to make them satisfying
both as problem solvers and in terms of
the production be of long-term education
and betterment of society optimistic
penis better information education make
them or read less at the center of his
analysis was an asymmetry we went to
Judas between the capacity for small
number of people to make problem
impulsive decisions including pursuing
profits and ways to generate those
negative externalities which are Steve
develop and the large bird people
effectively Dooley was an unusual
American in that he was explicitly alien
in part thanks they remembered it's
practiced of the big alien cited has
brought a significant and here he put
forward a proposition very much like
Marxist vision of how class in itself
become passports we suggested that
publix were objectively formed from all
those affected by social actions but
became subjectively effective when they
were born in eyes and self-aware he
showed a clear awareness of our scale
active public's depended on social
nations that work best under developed
both modern state unity dependence on
technology and far exceeds the limits of
face-to-face community 35 years after
doing yoga Hamas responded to the
situation he saw in post-war Germany in
a context of cynicism about democratic
institutions however mosque set out to
show the unrealized potential of the
public sphere as a category for fall
society I am now a filter part that
everybody speaks on the public sphere to
mention in your arms um that's a little
more however must all looked at formerly
democratic institutions that have been
introduced after for a dream in which
administrators have been carry over from
previous Nazi regime and public Silas
rain set on many important issues the
situation all too much resembled
Lippman's notion of the public sameera
phantom mist harbor muscles boutique
behind these republican disguise is in
some considerable part that publicness
is what's missing from german bombers
and he needs it in a range of different
senses and in fact translation of it
these have been something like bonus on
the way and have to be a specially
mounted of its fear the pyramids idea is
that an animating part of public life
democracy is public life is openness is
transparency is talking about things
that we may otherwise silence as well as
engaging more important in their passion
for pleasure decision this was precisely
picked up on my expert member who
applied leverage Theodor Adorno and who
shaped the rejection of our losses book
as is the discussion at Frankfurt
leading him to go tomorrow they rejected
it precisely because they hold it valla
jurist that is it would do but not
season done encourage the less educated
people in society to participate
actively in public and this would be
dangerous so the space of this arc
outline in significant ways now
por otra mas there were negotiations
going on negotiations for example on
business labor political leaders but not
open the days about the character
society should assume are still less
implications than not see past it wasn't
just Germany with the Nazi past versions
of this Seahawk brainwipe in contrast
such negotiations among interest groups
however us celebrated the emancipatory
potential of a collective discourse
about the nature of the good and the
directions of state fashion this would
be free insofar as it was rational that
is based on the success of argument and
fatigue rather than force of either
status or coercion awesome app for a
moment a lot of talk and a lot of
prognosis interesting how to
operationalize them the idea is not a
complicated idea is that the best
argument wins in a debate rather and
some reference to who is making the
argument and this has some interesting
operationalization like the prominence
in the late 18th century of anonymous or
pseudonymous letters of those papers in
the u.s. case that a variety of versions
the prominence of people not using their
explicit personal identity to sign
currencies and public officials filled
all systems we are tend to say now a
great problem to the injured
is the anonymity behind the statements
of people who easily become trolls who
date's the conversations and I've turned
to hate speech but it was in fact
praised by the leaders and many of the
important particulars of the bogus
Bertha late eighth century most
frequently playing golden age because it
was the way to ensure that it was the
argument and not the arguer the
dominated the discussion so this is a
way of dealing with state experiences
the public sphere are my suggestion
could achieve community in some part by
disregarding those particular statuses
and particular interests in favor of the
general good he called for renewal of
what he described as 18th century a.d
the notion that ever wider circles
private individuals could join
international pretty cool base although
this is an ideal notifies you know like
Adam Smith I'm not always support
activities as well spanning social
circles disregarding their differences
of status identifying public good
comment to the mall and their whole
society is
the salesman public policy the best
version of the public sphere he wrote
was based on what a kind of social
intercourse that far from presupposing
equality of status disregarded status
falls gun in other words the solution to
problems of inequality was not
necessarily to eliminate the material
inequality first in order to have a
better public but to disregard
differences of inequality in the
institution restructured nature of life
in order to be able to activate really
good this worked by a mutual willingness
said to accept the human roles and
simultaneously centenary out this trace
the extract the attractiveness of this
idea is demonstrated by the remarkable
spreadeth term durable correct
Emmanuel's lovely introduction of me in
one small particular she said that my
vagina which is actually best book was I
must know look I'm sure that's not true
I'm sure my best known book is
awesome public sphere which is not a
demonstration by Williams for the
importance of low-power us and this
particular concept and term as they
emerged what they phrase the public
sphere not only gained prominence circle
academic disciplines but also became a
staple of journalism and wider public
discussions about state of democracy and
contemporary society debates over the
public sphere burrows China India Brazil
Egypt South Africa elsewhere public
sphere join suit society as a central
theme in discussions post-communist
transition European unification and
expirations the possibly cosmopolitan
global future it's not insignificant
that other losses book is published 62
translated his most European languages
other than English but the english
translation appeared in 1989 using the
phrase public sphere of a currency in a
new context of debates the book and
frenches discuss complete and in many
versions of it is a difference
translation is no story about
translation this recent is but in this
one the 27 year delay in public
an English translation I'll made the
book appear in a very delicate leg and
get tied up the notions of civil society
democratic transitions we're doing that
scene publix as responses to specific
issues drawing in all those affected
power loss identified a more or less
stable zone apologies the public sphere
located between civil society and the
state grounded in the former and
addressing the latter this was not
simply an abstract ideal our boss argued
you can see this in the very form of the
ball it is promises only book which has
the structure at least in part first
half of an historical narrative will
concrete
position this ideal was made me a mystic
by the development of a new pattern
social organization ideas since the late
17th century that created social basis
adequate to sustain newspapers and
emulsions for example hamas didn't
invent the wonderful term capitalism and
nick anderson invented it to talk about
the spread of nationalism but it is what
hamas is talking the way in which a
certain kind of business institution the
newspaper was facilitative to a
transformation of culture and collective
self understanding of large populations
coffee houses in which among other
things read the newspapers altima loud
and other publicly accessible spaces for
equally important and indeed states
increasingly attentive to public opinion
important our most elaborated social
foundations of an effective public
sphere and considerably more historical
death in doing though a variety of
people in writing HD pieces work on that
ever since the issue of foundations the
infrastructure the public life is
important the first place the
infrastructure terms the abstract
normative attention
communication into imminent possibility
secondly the infrastructure gives publix
their conscience you asked about access
and who gets him doesn't and no literacy
for example the 18th century flourishing
public sphere was without nasara see
every europe so this particular golden
age was structured on the basis of print
media that word themselves intrinsically
exclusive now they didn't admit only the
rich and powerful there is to transfer
the emerging law they admitted a variety
of craft workers and others but they
were highly selective in the
organization secondary transmission that
is weave them aloud in pubs or coffee
houses to people who weren't later
expanded this but it's not as
significant that the version takes place
in a context where the technological
infrastructure is restricted it's not
completely different from the base about
the extent to which people do or do not
have access to the web today in various
development
for other contacts
the shaping is not just a poison
participant term abscess is slightly
misleading the shapes who is connected
to home in a variety of ways organizes
the interim apology of the pelvis as
well public communication is organized
noxious by the conscious choices for
participants moreover but as a
by-product the organization of settings
and media for communication most
efficient horse don't have their purpose
as created a democratic public sphere is
doing something else beginning of the
newspaper story involves merchants who
want to get price data from other cities
that and the track courts and so forth
they business instead of coffee houses
our business
opera's emphasize the late 18th century
transition from aristocratic salons and
early literary magazines to both more
open and more political discussions on
new foundations stressed that as
newspapers grew as businesses he
revealed that crucial supports the
public communication can in fact come on
for-profit economic basis when the
argument is to suggest remind us that
the notion of civil society is actually
rounded upon an appreciation for
capitalism businesses part 6 of the
society at the same point with Adam
Smith who's accounted the invisible hand
is in part a demonstration it's intended
to show that people can reorganize
outside the control Kings a government
that they can self-organize we have come
to equate both business and garland with
district systems by continent impending
on paper this was not big
as later critics noted harbor loss
account is quality in various regard to
not go through kinds of Matisse one
striking them is that neither science
nor religion figures it is neither of of
what might be considered the two largest
waves precursors from our public sphere
in Europe the rise of science with its
into small colleges emits communication
networks nor the religion with printed
sermons churches illness figure
destroyed we very well starting the
story 17 rather than oasis now changes
in technology and social organization
continue to matter and they naturally to
the present day all sorts of other
things happen issues your mail on the
same this television happens but public
management or subsidy license fees your
subscriptions Russia sponsorship similar
sorts of
spirit however Moscow left implicit one
of the most important infrastructures
Republic city's never discussed remain
Athena book is the rise to the city as
itself part of the story of publicness
the urban our public life was
overwhelmingly in Berlin phenomena
Margaret squares and certain street
corners were important public spaces not
just coffee shops public houses Gardens
parks churches schools supportive public
gatherings while some gruis all
businesses others real objects of
collective struggle and state guarantee
as citizens try to ensure that they
would have a space is becoming life and
this is a story again different local
and national characteristics throughout
Europe also that out of our mouths story
as Ostrogoth necked include the things
they are
totally happen our portrait worker
starts the park the workers struggles
fully embrace Lynette was a struggle for
public space and their tosin makes nice
point about greenham common in London
precognitive Newbridge they are after
remember for anti nuclear weapons
produce armament protests nearly
invisible war is over it's also
significant that these were among the
most prominent women led protests on the
new Europe defense the Greenham common
exists only because it had been fought
for by workers in too late 18th century
trying to preserve cause trying to
preserve open spaces for various
purposes including leisurely walk not
only for colored wire so there's a
longer story story that involves a
struggle in a different sense and
destroyed is over in his space of cities
this is not trivial today because cities
are changing dramatically in this regard
is to invoke it the early modern cities
into the very beginnings of 19th century
we're cities that I serve operatic
character
they were staged around central squares
and angles the stories of successive
French Revolutions always figure to
eternity they fear certain stations
there's a sense in which of the Menace
of opera becomes the herb popular
politics at its birth and popular
politics is marked by a kind of
pageantry that will be organized in
public space but also by the physical
located pneus of some of the objects of
state power in fact sees the autonomy in
a way you can't seize on the
institutions even in still centralized
in France the city's changed be honest
they have proportionately less public
space part of the drama occupy wall
street does that isn't counting part the
public space like mine is private
property structured so in the course of
development rezoning that is it was to
be not built on but it wasn't actually
public and there is a reorganization a
fine structures public space of access
to public space who and all here we see
speech the European American differences
to note about one of them that Americans
are much less tolerant of surveillance
even though more willing in some
to have other kinds of identities
written in particular but actually blood
sugar is vastly more comment it is
filmed all the time Europe is the
treasure right oh that is everything is
on film all the time everywhere in
public there are no fewer than 67 Paris
plant revolvers they're all time I now
this is something that bears on public
space in cities in a sweet way now small
towns and villages also have spaces for
gatherings ecology can go out and town
center the issue isn't district cities
had more and now a loser it is that the
cities these spaces more often bring
strangers together publicness is
necessarily share but publicness is only
one form of sharing that which is over
to strangers to people who are not
connected to each other
with personal relations there's a
slippery issue of scale of we could we
wouldn't call a family exactly a micro
public community is usually people
understood how any relationships to each
other as my awareness argument
publicness as in part two of the
sociability of strangers and even more
it has to do with being able having
capacities to navigate the world of
strangers to set for example fancy
speaks call of a man of the public
Madison who's comfortable in situations
that have no links or parallels but his
familiarity and traces again Houston
ization in Paris that arrived at stories
of transformation of European cities
where they change public spaces here
Jane Jacobs praised the public character
of 19th century cities sidewalk cafes
and human scale and mixed-use
neighborhoods and deportes lost in
twentieth-century transformations now
there's a long story large furniture and
not much time so I'm going to go on and
talk about other great leaders to be
about our event scribe mills variety and
others who contribute to this
today and transforming history I left
shift gears and briefly before ending
raising issues assess conversating to
live it up this county and the first one
has to do with decisions of cities and
that word that idea of the meta topical
that's a top agency place we can see if
I talk about markets
it was common usage to speak of a market
as a place not so long you went to your
market that could mean a score of animal
fur on your course meant a mark like a
town market than organized on sale
produce through the countryside around
it or goods that were brought in from
other towns in a growing vision flavor
make shoes and so forth and markets are
closely related to profits they remind
us that not all relations among
strangers article or they stop the same
sense and then not all relations that
are open constitute crimes thinking
about this is tricky of when markets
were in fiscal places to our basis
sometimes the coincidence could be very
strong Pollux and public knowledge
comparing a public information move a
large part from markets from people
coming together in markets and gossiping
at the same time there
trading goods and sharing news news
could spread from one market town to
another in circles and there are a
variety of that person networks or this
came to the market to buy and sell stuff
but also to acquire a disseminate
information the news tab very sweat so
even before the newspapers the earlier
versions were pioneers the public sphere
the 18th century we're connecting up
their different coffee houses global
settings but in this we see at the
beginning of a change markets become
some extent and that's top what that
term means in this context is a velvety
actually burst that we begin to speak of
the market as all of these exchanges
summed together it loses its connection
to place our from longer distance the
frisson of distances reduced but also
the market becomes understood as a set
of functional mechanisms that are going
to supply demand and so I look at work
and so we have not only a market market
in this town in your mark in that town
but the mark the market is in his early
modern constructions stories
a state structure of understanding that
it intercourse expanding on global and
always but the same thing happens to the
public and distance ask and this is key
to the Harbormaster news there are just
public's pasta saying there is people
the organized pub country the public
sphere it's organized in relationship
states transcended space as one of the
challenges today but it's also
conceptually drinking and I won't go
into this in motion tails it just
announced two things talk about went to
the office um the idea that topical is
also a claim that different topics are
in fact all of the same public so one of
the lines of critique that has come
about public spheres is actually
something very directly out of what we
talked about that is is there a public
sphere that is the same public sphere
when you want to discuss women's rights
and housing prices but what are those
different public's different posters in
different countries it's the claim this
is key to getting democracy is that
there is a convergence that these
various topically and more spatially
distinct public's converge substantively
into this meta topical space and then
over Dudley meza top Republic
constitutes the demas of democracy such
that there can be collective action and
decision through the public this is um a
theoretical challenging puzzle now I'll
ask your sections are all innocence or
telegram and so talk about this relation
to early 19th century industry folks but
we go back to the issue note it's
implicit in the LC occupy question but
again is it the case that to be a public
requires boundaries or requires and
dispensing with batteries what is the
right answer they occupy students is tom
acrobat
right what's the right answer they are
giving in one respect a very classic
late 18th century ask all this is the
year of corresponding societies of the
notion of the Republic of Letters and if
the idea of mid words on religion that
the public classically had to be about
members unlimited unbounded parrot this
had to do with the moving Tom Paine I
present to America back to France not
pertinent eventually is gold is very
much comet right that there is a
national look look but it wasn't just
foundations strong idea of unbounded
local members unlimited and this of
course be involved students to say we
won't really be free if you restrict us
if you say well lse students have rights
to occupy but we can't bring in all the
other students from Amsterdam where does
that this is not freedom but this is
about public's attention to the word the
same time it's a limit on the idea of
this meta topic relationship that is
unconstitutional demons the absence of
boundaries and the absence of what we
might call
differential density of social networks
is a an important issue the Constitution
could be awesome through building
connections not some people to be
doubled in relation to the state of is
crucial and different from the
dispersing of connections law members
unlimited an extremely large scale the
two of them coexist uneasily in this
history similarly the idea of counter
publics and pelvis is a concern it's a
turn introduced count republic by necked
included to point out the power must
fail to talk about not were lawful exit
rebellion same time be in public and
expect which the public sphere wasn't
just made by these relative athletes but
by contestation radicalism of the extent
to which the public sphere was always
fought over all the time that
harbormaster's narrative is in what
sense mislead it posits this creation of
republic in days bourgeois institutions
and then problems that arise as it
expands i think i was created in part by
exposure is it was in declaring that the
public would not include a variety of
subaltern or other courses we could
enforcing this by things like taxes on
these papers to increase the prices such
that they could be read only
as literacy stop being a detective on as
normal people to read otherwise
introduced I want my current business
story Butler suggests is that there is a
reality to this issue and there's
something dis leading about it reality
is of course that there are these
contests for Republicans butts
misleading is that very few people are
ever happy to be accountable counter
publics are generally alternative claims
to the dominant colors the early 19th
century tracks Britain and elsewhere
there are a variety of more or less
working class phones the air our new one
of them distances they are not shaped by
other rejection very bourgeois their
shape I think might lead to soften up
being left out of everything George
wrong about blocks mobility
opportunities the same thing is true in
Britain and there are great things
William politics talking journalism
story was really nice and century
everything from the best-selling English
crown ever up to of the founder of
password
public records power words to people's
registered for activism is furious
repeatedly furious about being described
as a special interest finger as though
they were first for his audience for
special interests even watching jay
fuller and the black work say he figured
in this history of contests a defender
of print over public galleries because
he thinks only people to be reason to
being but someone who would not be happy
to be a republic because his claim
is to democracy to the dean loss and to
the right of everyone to enter it and
shake its constitution so there's a
significant
to counter publics I think through
Holden they're not a happy story but you
can have to fill dyscalculia right they
are a part of a story conversation to be
the next time well this conversation the
challenges go over robot a feature the
classic public sphere idea is that it's
oriented towards actress meaningful
experience all of the examples of shape
Devon Lawson kinds of discussions have
an orientation classically usually the
state and the public sphere derives is
as English long as your preference for
Louis therefore Angelina state because
the public sphere lacks executive power
almost by definition so the public
sphere is organized to some vehicle
preparing that out here to the edge of
darkness we need to see how it fits into
the kind of story that Karl Polanyi
outline is double movement the
destruction of pre-existing solidarity
is a craft communities by
industrialization of building a new ones
column comments Pilate is interested in
new ones like insurance systems or
welfare space systems and these are
indeed built in the response to the loss
of family community social support
systems but it's worth thinking of
in this sense is you're welcome that is
the creation of public as itself a form
of solder not being the public before
playing various other material business
but the rebuilding through newspapers
through communication through foreign
masters of a new kind of solidarity and
one of the links citizenship
nation-state good all it's also worth
noting is iSAGEN already there are other
actors to influence businesses and there
are civil society organizations like
flank for any manner of problems that
are safe Lonnie's products social needs
that are not being met because they will
forms be disrupted there are various
different kinds of choices that out to
meet the state programs you can be
killin market mechanisms even with
philanthropy charity there are a range
of these sources and do some organized
civil society this was our food the
whole modern period I haven't really
talked too long could take it now into
the struggles over its abacus and
pointless of boar is anarchism Network
possibility for reorganization so in
Barcelona
self-organized of support in urban
communities is that to be found in
currently wanting because of its
inability of scale up of two large scale
or is this the building of large-scale
politics news this is important because
to business limit to conventional colors
and having some people already discussed
is the limits two states the extent to
which safe boundaries either via your
problems the migration as they go on
fundamental issues who gets he named us
on the basic ways of or the limits
imposed up by the opposite notice
unlimited and the disc organization a
very large scale public's citizenship
isn't open yet this isn't any moment and
a global customer some publix can be
question is the extent which they can be
heavy patience and who they address in
order the applications let's say
actually stays restore the center
Department have venison participation in
the wool is extremely hierarchically
organized my participation in European
colors on the early modern Europe that
grew into a larger scale mask moment we
should write off possibility of trans
national problems but we have other
sorts of problems like the fact that say
in case of Europe the most important
language of transnational European
communication doesn't stay specifically
european english is the factor global
languages of the video organized in
english don't produce national
solidarity the way to national language
newspapers of that produced their common
public satirical extent there's the
issue of the mountain publix fixes back
to this underlying question of what we
mean but in demoss models those were
comments on it and say what we want mean
is building the d-mail stop funding it
and then asking whether there is an
adequate public sphere servant but
publicness as a seven
Derrick talked about this in Europe is
when you can utilize we are indeed in a
situation where ideals and institutions
are radically divergent about us oh and
we can go into me do any other persons
but I need clothes so let me go to
including thought contrived okay are you
a much longer list of ways in which
public mrs. challenge one significant
part of that would go back to the
discussions of surveillance and the way
in which they differ in Europe us the
whole set of issues of unattractive
publicness you begin to help a study
around the different reactions to Google
or the different reactions to comment
various information to help ease in
Europe near
and are around us and different ideas
people struggle with how to constitute
of legitimacy information technology
throughout all this I think you would
find reason to doubt the adage
attributed up to Stuart Brennan Pollard
catalog confirmation industry that
information wants to be free we find
that information it wants anything else
he must be free is organizing a variety
of forms of other freedoms and freedoms
their complexity and try and that are
very much tied up with state law office
differences so how can i generate a
little bit of hopefulness oh well 2
times 1 is but it may be little moments
that are the most important and not of
Engraving they'd rather there may be a
fundamental difference between how you
get in great institutions and how you
change and that what's missing
debate is the difference between very
short term existence like fantasies but
movements that last weeks or months or
years but go nowhere in terms of
institution building but change
imaginaries and understandings thank at
the long-term institution building which
usually ends up beginning to feel like
constraints even when it starts out
between us and the celebration of what's
experienced only in many moments as
though it were the ideal for the
permanent public sphere they make us
unreasonably cynical about futures pub
last not universe to reform itself
pelvic spear has been as shaped
universities the universities have
shaken it who experience in part a
preacher of intellectual life the early
accounts the server monitors
intellectual life asked voice many
European project management University
much it didn't take universities to have
the lives of ergonomic science
scientific revolutions are produced more
or less without universities
enlightened universe is coming to this
story in a significant way
19th century and they rise and yet
become by the 20th century important
mainstays of the public sphere there are
internal public's organizing
communication of scholars but they also
are parts of the larger problems in
every major wave of social movements
there are public spaces among the public
spaces in these university campuses
become official they are also
organizations of proximity and contact
on young people become part agonists and
protests social movements aquariums and
enduring sense they are usual
institutions to vote to information be
free there's one set of challenges that
universities face about how we work as
institutions in a world where the
organization of access to knowledge is
radically apartment accustomed
partly because a technology just lets
hop name and there's an important
European story develops but it's another
story what if universities are simply
becoming progressively irrelevant but if
the transformation is one in which this
particular need what is being that by
other institutions of emergencies and
the need to contribute to say to
large-scale discussion of major social
issues isn't mobilizing mainly magnetic
participation or the connections between
the academic status are we a different
sort and finally what if we have become
our own worst enemies that is the
internal public with universities is
sufficiently limited internal debates
and discussions on an arts like this is
owned by virtue of the extent to which
we are all organized in pursuit various
other objectives articles in top
journals departmental rankings on a
variety of purposes which are not easily
avoided and naturally back negotiating
with the occupiers they insist that
repository lasamba should be reduced
because there's the quality and the
whole staff and I try to explain to them
prior to the professor's knowledge but
up at the sunoco go somewhere else and
that there are some material constraints
how much inequality can be tolerated how
can it be organized who pays these sorts
of questions are still basic to public
life and they are basic to our internal
life in the universities as well and my
impression sadly just of my university
that in general is we are facing them
very